and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review
oh my god the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life
no what were you talking about Brad
June's Oh God look I saw this movie with
you and then all of a sudden I gained 80
pounds get a foot taller pubes all over
my face and Jake got a moustache I heard
sure I mean seriously what the fuck do
you find even good about this movie oh
no I thought this film was very unban
guarded it very things differ materially
different different okay you got the
fucking weird ass red and white montage
at the front end with a serif going to
Sancerre fun and then the tedious
exposition with all the cuts in was that
baby like CGI or something yeah but that
was intention of the baby being Gigi I
you know you were supposed to say like
hey that baby's not really there like
Bella Swan it's not really there you
know she's not a real care during that
she's computer-generated meaty well you
got that right she's our real character
I mean she just stood there like this
the whole movie huh I didn't think it
was possible for a CGI baby to be as
horrifying as that dancing goatee
commercial no but don't you see it's in
a lies to the Ally McBeal deeds remember
the new CG baby then everybody thought
it was cute
I mean I would have rather had Al McBeal
up on that screen at least I could
tolerate that look but dog goddamn Oh Oh
even let me lift it down really to what
this are all boiled down to and that is
the romance which granted there was very
little love in this film in fact most of
it was just being exposition for
exposition but I found it pretty closed
in July I found it pretty close well
once you started narrating out of
nowhere yes you narrate out of nowhere
they fuck out of nowhere and let me tell
you I haven't seen a more erotic sexy
than what Mass Effect 3 I don't know
open up a Korea but I think you guys are
just too cynical about this film I mean
you remember the Dakota Fanning's
incredible incredible role in this movie
all uh what three lines I think and
build lines were deliver visions you lie
Oh - oh you give her too much credit
like the borrower's you kill people with
her stare that was pretty cool yeah yeah
that was very very cool but I add
something the ending to this one that I
thought was very very clever I like the
way that we have Fame
right and then we have werewolf but then
we also have the planet tears in one
person people that control the elements
it wasn't it
so as central to the story did not just
make oh the difference in the will to
make that up okay so you're a vampire
you don't die in the sunlight you live
forever
you have unending stamina and then you
get other superpowers and they give this
one guy Benjamin all the powers of the
planeteers and get the planet at once I
mean yeah - the heart - we should put -
hard but he can just slam the ground and
cause a rift that goes into the center
there with lava because you know that's
how vampires work would you think I hate
you you know bottom line when I think of
this movie
I think the romance I think the element
I of course think of Dakota Fanning but
what about the idea of the Gollum guy
the guy that looked like Andy Serkis if
he actually had weight put on you know I
mean he I thought he was very subtle it
was a subtle performance and that was my
to have a Jew I got about 13 words Dale
guy I thought that was busy because for
the most part I thought he was very
reserved very he'll bag but then when he
actually sees the child and goes I
thought it was very moving I thought was
very very strong oh it's it seemed like
you could connect with what he was
thinking which was what was he thinking
he was thinking and I think so you're
right that that came across pretty well
don't you look at that guy and you think
to yourself oh that's going on in his
head is constant giggling obviously no
thought I just figure that's what's
going on in most of the characters heads
I hate everyone on that screen for
beginning to end
and then the movie had the balls to not
even give a proper payoff there's this
great ending where everyone is dying
they're getting their heads ripped off
in their jaw and then it doesn't
actually happen buzzer okay okay yes we
should probably address this this will
probably very controversial I even for
Twilight fans apparently for all the UH
buildup you could see for this movie
there is finally a gigantic climates
that quite frankly you could tell you
what happens and you will be okay I'll
tell you what happens though the
everybody line up all the way let's get
lined up let me just go ahead each other
mr. ripping each other's heads off and
they're flying everywhere and then these
people using their captain planner
powers but then they're like oh I'm
gonna use my psychic powers like when I
have oh my god I got and everybody's
doing jumping it's like Cirque du Soleil
and their girls are getting ripped off
and they're screaming and yelling all
this stuff and yet it turns out it was
all a dream
well no no wasn't even a dream it was a
vision being passed on to the big bad by
one of the girls I don't know where's
your name angel amber doesn't fucking I
was seeing dream to give it a little bit
more credibility oh come on come on okay
look you could you could try to be
classy about it like it hero or you
could be stupid about it like Twilight
Breaking Dawn - well you know and the
other thing that some people found very
uncomfortable in the air last movie was
when a Jacob actually imprinted on a
baby which I suppose means that they're
going to go steady yes yes and then at
the very end they imply very clearly
that baby she's gonna get boned by the
werewolf but here's the thing the baby
is now going to get boned they're gonna
wait till she grows up to get boned yeah
which could still be considered creepy
well there was that whole thing where
the pale one what your dad to be more
specific the one the window stairs oh
you mean the main guy with the Oh Edward
Edward yes he teaches whatever where
he's like hey don't do that to my
daughter which you I could understand
that if my little girls been born you're
like hey but then at the end he's just
like yeah okay go have sex with my
daughter
eventually no but didn't you think the
scene where he says hey should I start
calling you dad
no that was scary that was really scary
when they did that I hate everyone on
this screen and the best part is we know
how old he's gonna be when the boating
starts could be seven years cuz
apparently when you're half mortal and
half mortal
it means you grow up in seven years and
stay immortal yes it wasn't real
confusing
much time passed for the child they just
did a mood dissolve and something she
was talking we have no idea this was
weeks or years or literally as we're
watching it seconds we're not really
sure and but but thank God the Father in
the movie Bella's father he's a smart
cookie I think he is because he looks at
this kid that used to be a baby and now
clearly as a child he's like okay I'm
charlie is so fucking dance this entire
movie he's like oh look you're a
werewolf oh this baby suddenly a frickin
five year old and I'm not gonna be a boy
I'm not gonna think of anything weird
and then oh look suddenly you just want
to save me on a fishing trip okay well
you know what see to me I think it made
it very clear that the father was
mentally ill because as you remember
Jacob reveals himself as a werewolf and
he's pretty much cool with it and then
when he asked Bella what's going on she
says she can't tell him and he's pretty
much cool with it so obviously he was a
very slow individual the whole thing
how did Bella forget how to be a human
oh man who died Jota I will defend this
even when she was human she was not
human she had to be shown how to be
human even when she was a human now give
me some credit there that was kind of
revealing yeah yeah I thought that's
very clear hi my favorite part was just
the whole things like of the other
vampire scouting here saying learned II
don't know since to straight don't look
military because humans don't fucking
sit up and be sure to move your
shoulders or else people won't think
you're breathing now I will ask you this
do you think that maybe the excessive
use of people going in fast motion
because even the air moves I don't
remember that it was starting to look
like a Benny Hill sketch
would you agree my favorite scene was in
the beginning when Bella and Edward just
running through the woods and it's so
fake and then she smells the guy
bleeding from a mile away just jumps and
climbs up a hill I was like come on spy
him the fucking neck and no pay off no
pay off my poo will run to do anything
they will run to get books off of
bookcases they run to sit down and then
at the end of the movie when one
character has to run away she turns
around
smoothly for some fucking reason okay
okay
bottom line as we get to the end of this
review I think that quite clearly you
two individuals are missing that this
was obviously supposed to be a comedy
think about it think about it I mean you
have this woman who has clearly done
nothing that young woman she she has
done nothing accomplished nothing even
at the very end when all the action is
happening what has been accomplished
nothing it is hilarious now I think it's
hilarious others a CG baby I think it's
hilarious how Bella Swan is drip from a
human to vampire even though she never
had any human qualities and actually now
that she's a vampire she may even have a
few more human qualities because at Lisa
- Lily explained at the end we're going
around to take it off each other's heads
into werewolves are like that rattle and
in the guy smashes the ground and
everything fault is like why did he do
that in the first place if it's all a
dream it's the most hilarious thing I've
ever seen in my life yeah but you guys
laughing this is the last time I'm
taking in my car you know that right
why did you let him in the first place
this is history bumsang yeah you guys
had a cup of some kind
uh no hey um if there's a bank here I
would use to detect a change you can
change let it sit with you what's in
here who a Jesus perfect chick-fil-a you
anti-gay bastards
come on happen yeah you know what I feel
dirty just using that Ike this could
take a minute um bye